so let's talk about coronavirus deaths
for
weeks almost for two months the right
and the anti-science crowd were telling
us don't worry
cases are up but deaths aren't going to
go up and we would say
why not and they would come up with
explanations like well
listen um you know it's young people now
who are getting the virus young people
don't get very sick they don't go into
the hospital they don't die
so even though cases are spiking
starting in mid-june we're not going to
see a spike in deaths
um some others would say it's a less
serious strain now the virus is mutated
and it's far less serious now
others said we're better at treating it
deaths won't go up we've got
you know hydroxy and redeserver
and we're just not going to see that
death spike because we're better at
treating it
well for the like the 10th time in the
last month
we again have set a 30 to 60 day
new high-water mark in terms of deaths
and yesterday
1485 people died of coronavirus
1485. that's half a 9 11 in a single day
this is the most deaths yesterday since
may 27th or about 64 days
we are quickly losing all the progress
that was made
during april and early may we're back
at the may 27th death number if you look
at the brown line
on the graph that we have up on the
screen that's the seven day moving
average so
sometimes looking at individual days can
be less than a complete picture because
we tend to get less
reporting on the weekends so if you look
at a seven day average
you can see that the seven day moving
average of deaths has been climbing
since
right around the fourth of july holiday
here in the united states
that should have been a signal that
things weren't being done correctly it
has now been almost a month since then
as you probably know by now deaths are a
lagging
indicator to cases so even if we believe
that cases started to flatten on july
16th now many of us don't believe that
because that's the day on which
reporting from hospitals
shifted from going to the cdc instead
going to trump's department of health
and human services
but if you believe that cases started to
flatten on july 16th
then that means we are still weeks
from the peak in terms of single day
deaths and that means that 10 or 14 days
from now
the daily death toll could be once again
tragic
it could get to a 911 every day
or just short of it now as you know as
it's almost become apocryphal at this
point
but i've been saying massachusetts has
handled the virus quite well
but if you're all in the same pool and
someone's peeing in the deep end and
you're in the shallow end
eventually you're going to get some of
that pee in the shallow end if you
understand what i'm saying eventually
it's going to reach you we're all in the
same pool and even here in massachusetts
it's a slow uptick but there's an uptick
and it started in mid-july
we had you know 175 200 cases a day for
weeks
we're now more regularly getting 300 325
cases a day
and we're about to see is it fifty
thousand is it a hundred thousand a
hundred and fifty thousand college
students flying in
over the next four weeks to start
college and
add to that that we're about to get hit
with the flu season in the united states
i'm seeing cvs and walgreens
advertising flu shots i'm going to get
mine very soon
this could be ramping up to arguably the
worst or most difficult
fall in the united states from a public
health standpoint
i will just say in a very long time does
it go all the way back
uh to 1918 and the flu i'm not sure but
certainly
in decades people just aren't listening
much of the world did handle this this
was not the only way that it could have
gone the trajectory in the united states
i hate that it has become political but
because donald trump did fail us
he has to suffer the consequences he has
to be removed
in november i don't even need a
president that will do anything that
special we just need one that will do
i i was just interviewed actually on a
new zealand um
program and we'll be posting that uh
very soon to youtube and facebook
jacinda ardern in new zealand she didn't
bring any unique medical
knowledge she just realized that she
shouldn't pretend to know things she
doesn't know
she's going to defer to the doctors and
let the doctors lead the way
with her support that's all i need a
president to do
but we are now back where we were months
ago we're sort of starting from scratch
in a sense there are discussions about
needing a full lockdown reset to get
things under control
i don't think there's any political
appetite for that at this point in time
and think about all of the people who
stayed home
for months sacrificed financially
sacrificed you know psychologically and
emotionally to flatten the curve
we're back to where we were back then
and we are still
up against mass evictions growing
unemployment
consider the disrespect by the way to
the healthcare workers
remember they're heroes we appreciate
them right well then
why isn't everybody wearing a mask how
is it respectful to healthcare workers
to walk around with no mask and to have
indoor dining and have casinos open in
movie theaters
we haven't done the right thing for them
as much as for the victims of the virus
it's disgusting
it's tragic and the next three months
it could be really bad it could be
really really bad
uh and i want to hear what's going on in
your state i am on twitter at deepakman
let me know how you see it let me know
what's taking place